bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtone en direct
je m'appelle anne-marie vivent
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder un sujet
drôlement intéressant parce que je me
sens concerné vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
en fait c'est l'intérêt de ces personnes
de toutes origines mais aussi des
personnes venues d'ailleurs pour les
autochtones
là il ya beaucoup de monde autour de la
table on va tout de suite faire les
présentations
on va commencer par le coin gauche will
prosper alors will je vais prendre les
feuilles pour être sûr de pas me tromper
vous faites beaucoup de choses
documentariste journalistes et vous êtes
aussi un militant des droits civiques et
des droits humains
vous réalisez en ce moment des
documentaires sur quoi vous travaillez
actuellement que ce moment je travaille
sur un documentaire sur l'histoire de
fredy villanueva en essayant de l'encré
dans ce qui s'est produit au québec et
je commence au début de la naissance de
fredy villanueva
avec la crise d'oka je l'expliquerai par
la suite c'est quand même une histoire
qui est celle à raconter parce qu'on la
diversité sato toujours été sujet
ambigüs oui ça très intéressant voyait
revenir deuxième éviter yves loiseau
vous êtes journaliste vous êtes en fait
un correspondant installé au canada
depuis quelques années je m'installe ici
parce que mes filles ont quitté la
france pour venir s'installer ici donc
j'ai deux fils et deux sont là donc j'ai
cru qu'il était préférable pour la
famille coste regroupe d'accord et donc
pour pouvoir rester ici parce que j'ai
76 ans chez un vieux monsieur
donc je suis correspondant pour pouvoir
entrer et sortir avec un visa qui me
permet de rester ici six mois d'accord
voilà j'ai eu la chance dès mon premier
séjour de faire la connaissance des
amérindiens
ma fille était à saint félicien au cégep
et j'ai eu la chance d'entrer de jeu de
visiter le musée de mashteuiatsh ou
ça m'a passionné c'est à la suite de ça
que j'ai commencé à m'intéresser aux
premières nations
voilà marie pierre bousquel étant skype
avec nous installer dans son chalet dans
les laurentides marie-pierre bon c'est
pas dans les laurentides
d'ailleurs le lieu secret assez bien
alors marie-pierre vous êtes à
l'université de montréal où département
d'anthropologie études autochtones
vous y êtes depuis longtemps
l'université de montréal ça fait déjà 10
et pan os
d'accord le temps passe vite et vous
êtes d'origine française et je suis
d'origine française effectivement voilà
et vous avez un grand intérêt pour les
autochtones aussi on va expliquer et
puis évidemment nos deux chroniqueuses
habituel alors ellis queen bonjour il y
j bonjour hellich aujourd'hui vous allez
vous nous nous parlait d'un homme un
américain en fait il vit aux états unis
mais il s'intéresse aux inuit wissam al
mana 30 ans maintenant qui est sereine
dans une village en particulier une
village inuit dans l'extrême arctique
des territoires du nord-ouest
on peut parler un peu de sang paco et
puis un livre qu'elle est sortie sur ce
la communauté oui évidemment la dernière
et non la moindre isabelle picard
autochtones on joue originaire de
wendake et donc une date de wayne
d'accueil alors vous allez pouvoir vous
faire l'avocat du diable
lors de cette conversation parce qu'on
se demande mais moi je ne me demande pas
pourquoi je m'intéresse aux autochtones
et en plus sur un espace autochtones
depuis trois ans mais pourquoi des gens
venus d'ailleurs s'intéresse très
particulièrement aux autochtones will
votre intérêt pour les autochtones il
est né quand ou mais aussi bizarrement
que ça pourrait paraître c'est pas si
bizarre que ça en fait je suis
documentariste c'est la première fois
que j'ai vu les communautés autochtones
c'était à travers un film à l'école qui
a été présenté et sa hotte allumé ma
passion pour le documentaire que ma
passion pour découvrir qui sont les
autochtones parce que c'est pas une
histoire qui est vraiment bien
rencontrer dans nos livres d'histoire
malheureusement et d'un autre événement
qui était catalyseur aussi
danser compréhension la gelée mentionné
d'entrée de jeu c'est la crise d'oka
j'étais très jeune à l'eau points à
l'époque oui et c'était une
incompréhension totale des documents que
je voyais devant mes yeux et je
regardais mes parents on sait qu'ils
regardaient c'est celle là et je vais
toujours me rappeler jusqu'à la fin de
mes jours c'est quelque chose que je
pourrais jamais oublier de voir tous ces
gens là qui lançaient des roches sur les
véhicules qui est en train de sortir à
cette époque même et ça m'a profondément
marqué je me suis dit comment tant
qu'êtres humains ont pu y arriver jusque
là
et comment on peut ne pas connaître
notre histoire aussi donc c'est à lui
mais justement c'est ce goût de
découvrir un peu plus sur les
communautés autochtones ces deux feux
parce que vous il contrairement à nous
trois vous êtes né au québec mais vous
êtes né à montréal nord où enfin nous
coince vraiment d'une famille d'origine
haïtienne aviez-vous déjà côtoyé des
autochtones dans votre petit quartier
absolument pas
gg aucunement côtoyer des autochtones
j'en ai jamais vu c'est un peu quelque
chose qui était de l'ordre du mythique
quelque chose qui était complètement
dans notre imaginaire je le voyais à
peine dans les cahiers d'histoire aussi
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaissait donc il fallait que je fasse
beaucoup de découvert beaucoup de livres
m'intéresser à beaucoup de faits main
dessus et la manière que les femmes
étaient constitués à l'époque où si
c'était pas forcément les autochtones
qui est en train de porter leur propre
histoire donc c'était la vision du
touriste qui regardaient des communautés
autochtones qui nous raconter leur
histoire donc plus j'ai vieilli bien sûr
plus j'ai commencé à découvrir mais des
gens qui sont issus de ces communautés
là et d'en apprendre beaucoup plus sur
les communautés autochtones et la
richesse et la nécessité d'en parler de
plus en plus de faire rayonner cela
aussi est aujourd'hui j'essaie même
d'organiser des événements ou est ce que
les communautés de montréal-nord donc
les jeunes qui ont grandi comme moi plus
voyager jusqu'à des territoires et nous
pour aller voir comment leur réalité
peuvent être communes notamment aussi
peuvent apprendre aussi souverain et
nous les peuples autochtones et et
pourtant isabelle la crise d'oka a eu un
double effet il ya les gens qui ont eu
un intérêt favorable un préjugé
favorable vis-à-vis les autochtones qui
ont envie de mieux les connaître à cause
de ça il ya eu inverse
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya eu l inverse il
ya eu des moments difficiles après la
poste d'aucun la crise d'oka mais je
dirais que pour les premières nations
pour les premiers peuples ça a été un
peu un rêve est donc ça a été très
positif
et là mon expérience personnelle j'ai à
peu près l'âge de will
c'était mon premier était de travail en
tant que guide touristique wendat qui
est une communauté extrêmement
touristique donc on reçoit beaucoup de
français d'européens et crise d'oka j'ai
même pas 14 ans et là je dois expliquer
ce qui se passe et je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe je ne le comprends pas parce
qu'il faut réaliser que dans les livres
d'histoire nous dans nos programmes
d'histoire qu'on soit sur les
communautés où qu'on aille à l'école
leur communauté on ne les programmes
d'histoire que tout québécois 1 avec
très peu d'apprentissage notre propre
histoire et et c'est là qu'on se dit ok
je vais me poser les bonnes questions et
il ya tout plein de français d'européens
qui arrivent et qui me posent des
questions profondes beaucoup plus
profonde que les québécois peut me poser
ce qui peut me poser comme question est
là c'est là que j'ai eu
le goût de dire ok je vais m'aligner
versa je vais faire mes recherches
soient menées dans l'histoire
l'anthropologie l'ethnologie et c'est ce
que j'ai fait et là vous dites les
français ont enfin les touristes
d'ailleurs étaient très curieux de
contrats récurrents et pas les québécois
non il y avait vraiment on est vraiment
dans convié des années 90 il ya une
espèce de jeu c'est pas une froideur on
se parle pas beaucoup les québécois
souvent les plus vieux monde
ah oui moi dans les années 60 mon
grand-père on allait à la page tout ça
mais les générations d'adultes je
voudrais que nos yeux peut on se côtoie
pas vraiment mal pas vraiment la crise
d'oka va faire en sorte que certains
vont s'intéresser on se demande donc à
ce qui se passe c'est quoi les mots des
autochtones y en ait beaucoup
malheureusement qui vont tourner le dos
pendant longtemps
ok peut-être quatre où cinq marie-pierre
dont vous êtes à l'université de
montréal depuis 17 ans originaire de
france vous comment l'intérêt pour les
autochtones et pour les diverses nations
à travers le pays est né alors moi c'est
une longue histoire donc je vais essayer
pas vous prendre trop de temps dans
l'émission mais elle est quand même une
petite généalogie de cette histoire là
ça a commencé en fait j'ai été élevé en
france avec on pourrait en fait sans
vraiment m'en rendre compte de plein
d'image sur les amérindiens des images
dans des bandes dessinées des films
il y avait dans beaucoup de magazines
pour enfants donc élevé à jouer aux
cow-boys et aux indiens moi j'ai fais
toujours là sport pour remédier aux
photos de torture avec des peintures
enfin alors que les tuniques bleues qui
gagne est pour mes cousins et je
regardais pas mal de western et plus
tard plus âgée j'ai commencé à trouver
des livres un peu par hasard sur sur les
autochtones parce que je me morice
qu'ils étaient devenus jeudi ils sont
devenus pas ces personnes là qui meurent
toujours dans les films et là j'ai
commencé à avoir la réalité
contemporaine
vous êtes extrêmement difficile
j'ai eu l'impression d'un énorme
mensonge en fait la ruhr été trahis pour
m'avez menti coupe ma vie et là je me
suis
10 j'ai envie d'en savoir plus et c'est
pour ça que j'ai choisi l'ethnologie
je me suis rendu compte d'ailleurs comme
je me sentais de paris sur des
connaissances sur plein d'autres peuples
mais il m'est resté sept
cette envie là et c'est pour ça que je
suis devenu anthropologue pour
m'intéresser
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes venu
vivre au canada
c'est pour ça que je suis venu vivre au
canada au départ j'ai fait mes études
avant de m'installer et puis j'étais
étonné parce que en arrivant des vins
car ils maudits français s'intéressent
aux amérindiens et et en plus de ça on
me disait tu vas aller dans une
communauté mais pour qu'ils prennent des
cours de self défense
comprenez rien du tout j'avais lu en
plus des romans par exemple de bernard
clavel ça fait le maudit sauvage oui
et mme bernard clavel avait des bonnes
relations d amitié profonde dans des
communautés notamment regarde beaucoup
j'étais moi j'étais très curieuse et je
comprenais pas du tout ce qui m'était 10
et et puis je suis respect et on fait la
pressage donc quand j'ai fini mes études
j'ai trouvé un poste de professeur à
l'université de montréal c'était un peu
pas forcément prévues dans un programme
très précis mais cette passion ne s'est
jamais jamais éteinte au contraire et
l'est encore plus vivre chaque jour
parce que je fais un métier
extraordinaire est en fait vous voyager
énormément sur le territoire vous
promener un peu partout dans des
communautés à travers la province de
québec en tout cas oui c'est un immense
privilège grâce à mes recherches et
grâce aussi aux amitiés que j'ai nouée
au fil de toutes ces années je peux pas
mal voyagé dans les communautés et c'est
des rencontres extraordinaires
est ce que c'est vous qui avez créé le
directeur fait le programme en études
autochtones à l'intérieur du département
d'anthropologie de l'ue dm oui c'est moi
qui les crée je vais pas créé tout seul
mais disons que je vais arriver avec
l'idée en un moment où tout le monde
avait envie existe j'ai pas mal
consulter des autres hommes aussi de mon
réseau et puis quand j'ai fait cette
proposition
la faculté j'ai rencontré d'autres
professeurs et en fait tout le monde
avait envie d'avoir
alors aujourd'hui ce que vous bien
entouré est ce que vous êtes entourés de
beaucoup d'autochtones pas assez à mon
goût
[Musique]
j'avais dit oui j'aimerais qu'il y en
ait beaucoup plus dans les universités
j'aimerais aussi qu'il y avait qu ils
deviennent professeurs ils en avaient
déjà quelques-uns mais largement passé
il y aura d'autochtones dans le monde
universitaire et mieux ce spa mais ça
isabelle je pense qu on ne contredira
pas main en vient à ce sujet ils veulent
oiseaux vous êtes au canada donc au
québec depuis sept ans et vous l'avez
dit vous avez découvert les autochtones
en vous rendant à pointe bleue en allant
visiter ce musée dont dans la communauté
de m'acheter wyatt au lac saint jean
ça a été quoi la révélation ce jour là
bas c'est les traiter les traités qui
sont affichées sur les murs et la
réflexion que je me suis fait comme ça
elle est brutale je me suis dit mais
comment les anglais ont pu accepter ça
après c'est la première réflexion qu'au
temps de traiter soit signé ou que le
contenu même des traités oui oui parce
que le il ya tout un tas de choses qui
ont été oubliés depuis
moi je demande que les gens revoient les
traités qui ont été signés à l'époque
alors je sais que on m'a fait plusieurs
fois la remarque en me disant que les
gens qui les avaient signé du côté
amérindiens c'était des gens qui ne
connaissaient pas la langue qu'ils ne
savaient pas écrire est que bien souvent
ils ont fait une croix à la place mais
moi le contenu des traités m'a semblé
formidablement entre guillemets libéral
ça c'est la première chose et puis
ensuite j'ai eu une autre chance c'est
d'être invité par l'american indian
institute en ontario sur la réserve
destination et j'ai rencontré le chef
oren lines avec lequel j'ai beaucoup
discuté c'est une voix parmi les
autochtones puisqu'il a été porte parole
à l'onu de toutes les communautés
autochtones de l'amérique du nord
j'étais le seul francophone
ça m'a beaucoup surpris d'ailleurs je
poserai des questions là-dessus est le
seul français et j'ai été pris à partie
en tant que français et puis j'ai pu
discuter avec avec le chef lion's parce
qu'on faisait partie de la même
commission d'étude sur
le respect des traités et je me suis
rendu compte que dans l'île de la tortue
pour utiliser le terme qui est utilisé
les communautés québécoises se faisait
un peu bande à part alors pour dire les
choses clairement ce jusqu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui je m'interroge comment se
fait-il que les onze communautés
autochtones n'ont pas plus de rapports
avec les autres communautés les îles de
la tortue de l'île de la tortue
parce que moi j'ai appris énormément de
choses là bas beaucoup plus de choses
que j'en ai appris ici ça c'est la
deuxième chose est la troisième chose un
jour avec ma femme on a décidé de
prendre la voiture et on a été au pitch
iwan on a pris la piste alors que tout
le monde nous avait dit qu'il fallait
surtout pas y aller que c'était très
dangereux etc
nous y sommes allés là et on a passé de
cheslea tiken jah les indications oui
bon je suis un habitué maintenant des
attikameks j'habite sur sur un lac qui
fait partie des territoires ddt ont cédé
donc je sais grâce au chef coocoo que
j'ai vu à manawan que la maison que j'ai
fait construire il reste sur un
territoire
atika m et puis je maintiens 7,7 ce
désir d'apprendre par la fréquentation
de michel knoell bon qui a beaucoup
écrit sur sur les communautés
amérindiennes louis bouthillier ma
référence voilà isabelle on pourrait
répondre à cette deuxième question
c'était au niveau des francophones ouais
ça mais en fait c'est vrai qu au niveau
du des communautés autochtones du québec
les communautés qui ont comme langue
maternelle ou longues secondes le
français
il va quand même y avoir une différence
au niveau des communications que les
communautés anglophone je pense à cannes
et sète à guegan a manqué beaucoup quand
même de deux liens de relations avec les
autres communautés autochtones du canada
oui mais les communautés francophones
c'est un peu plus l'un étant donné
probablement
maintenant les réseaux sociaux ont
changé la donne depuis quand beaucoup
beaucoup je me posais une question
directe vous aimez buron wendat chasser
wendat wendat
il ya deux autres communautés qui sont
aux etats unis
lorsqu'il ya eu la fin de la guerre
entre les iroquois et les algonquins
vous avait éclaté une partie la baisse
non mais y en a d'autres il yad'autres
également il ya par exemple le cas des
gg je vais perdre le fil le cadet pas
les micmacs mais ceux qui sont un peu
plus il ya toujours des deux côtés de la
frontière
des parallèles et moi je suis assez
sidéré de voir que du côté des
anglophones ont fait toujours référence
aux communautés qui sont situées de
l'autre côté de la frontière et jamais
chez les premières nations québécoises
qui ont toutes les malécites par exemple
les malécites il ya deux communautés aux
états unis il y en a une qui est à la
frontière du il ne faut jamais référence
à ça et moi j'entends jamais quand
j'entends les wendat parler d'eux-mêmes
j'entends jamais parlé des deux
communautés qui sont des ouailles en
date
oui ben moi j'en parle quand même très
bien c'est quand même quand même quand
c'est le moment quand c'est moi nous
autres c'est quand même connu au 15 mars
et puis affirme asti sait des choses
dont on part mais ça dépend pas thatta
qui a qui vous parlait évidemment
maintenant si je donne un atelier sur
les premières nations du canada y
commandement de mentionner le nombre de
communauté huronne wendat au canada mais
fière de ce véhicule c'est ça oui est-ce
que autant justement de ces communautés
venus d'ailleurs ou qui ont un intérêt
ce qui a encore beaucoup d'ignorance
est ce qu'on doit faire autant
d'éducation chez les ch et les québécois
ici que des gens qui ont ont quand même
cette curiosité on doit faire encore de
l'éducation c'est certain il ya encore
les gens qui viennent d'ailleurs arrive
quand je ferai en parallèle avec nous et
voir ce que j'ai vu je trouvais que les
français les européens ouverts mais des
questions plus profondes va au delà du
fait que quand il ya du vert cherche et
un peu les plumes puis chercher bon on
en a vu des trucs comme ça
tout ce qu'ils avaient rempli de photos
très 21 en amérique bon tout ça dans
marqueur parlais tout à l'heure mais on
m'a donné quand cette frontière là était
dépassé les questions devenait vite plus
profonde pourquoi vous fait comme ça
pourquoi il ya tant pauvreté pourquoi
vous êtes un peu mis à part pour quoi
bon oui et là ça nous ça nous force à
nous poser des grandes questions
donc ça c'est à l'époque les québécois
ne posaient pas énormément de questions
outre de nous raconter les souvenirs de
leur grand père bon maintenant les
choses ont un peu changé les québécois
vont poser des questions plus profond on
ira tranquillement une éducation qui est
en train de se faire depuis on donne aux
morts puis bon on n'a plus la parole
aussi dans les médias et on a une voix
et ça fait la différence
beaucoup d'universités aussi se sont
ouverts ont créé des programmes c'est le
cas à l'uqam c'est le cas à une vertu
montréal et ça aussi ça fait une
différence
mais je commence à donner un cours la
semaine prochaine qui s'appelle
introduction au monde autochtone ça va
faire deux ans que je le donne à l'uqam
j'ai une centaine d'étudiants ya quand
même beaucoup et je m'attends s est déjà
au niveau universitaire mais j'ai quand
même surprise du nombre de rounds du
niveau de connaissance de ces gens là
c'est pas en lice qui est dans les
journaux mais on va pas vraiment cherché
en dessous donc en cours comme ça pour
moi je le dis tout le monde devrait le
faire tout le monde qui entre à
l'université devrait avoir un cours
d'introduction à rio première nasraoui
donc là c'est vraiment la basse que
celle là bas c'est la base donc c'est
pas tout à fait au même niveau les
préjugés sont tenaces énorme et la
population mais il ya quand même une
belle ouverture de la part de plusieurs
québécois ça va on veut vous entendre on
veut on veut vous écouter et surtout ce
qui est intéressant comme première
nation j'écoutais elisapie tantôt qui
faisait une entrevue à pénélope et qui
disait être autochtone c'est cool mais
c'est vrai que c'est rendu cool parce
que on peut être tokten avant on avait
des dix emplois parce qu'on était
autochtones ça pouvait arriver mais on
devait fêter dans la petite boîte de du
ministère on était ou du musée où on
était mais maintenant on est capable
d'être qui on est culturellement
socialement d'amener des manières de
faire de voir les choses de travail et
qui sont différentes
ça fait vraiment toute la différence au
genou donc si une différence elle et
louis marie pierre à l'université de
montréal dans votre département
et alors évidemment c'est les études
autochtones est ce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autochtones qui fréquente mais aussi
beaucoup de non autochtone dans la
majorité des étudiants du programme en
études autochtones ne sont pas au top
mais on a quand même des étudiants
autochtones et on a remonté en
maintenant à l'université de montréal
des statistiques sur le nombre
d'autochtones puisqu'il ya une
possibilité de s'auto d identifier oui
quand on s'inscrit
on voit que le nombre de personnes qui
s'inscrivent à l'université de montréal
depuis qu'il ya la possibilité d'auto
identification ça augmente nettement
d'année en année ça c'est ça c'est une
très bonne nouvelle et les non
autochtones qui sont là qui sont il est
ce que ce sont des gens venus d'ailleurs
est ce que ce sont de plus en plus de
québécois voient là bas j'ai déjà il
faut savoir que les autochtones qui
s'inscrivent à l'université vont pas
tous en études autochtones parce que
forcément il n'en ressent pas forcément
le besoin ils sont pas forcément voué à
faire des études autochtones
ils ont tous leur projet en intérêts
voilà et donc ils ont toutes sortes de
champs d'intérêt de choses à apporter
également dans les pipelines qui
choisissent oui on études autochtones en
tant que telle la majorité des étudiants
que j'ai ce sont des québécois il ya
toujours des français et des belges des
suisses a toujours deux jours il y en a
toujours quelques-uns mais la majorité
des étudiants
ce sont des québécois et ça ça change
beaucoup par rapport aux années où au
moins bon ya fort longtemps j'étais
étudiante
parce que quand j'étais étudiante à
l'université était étudiante université
de montréal à l'université laval et pour
moi j'étais étudiante dans les cours sur
les autochtones
il fallait chercher les québécois y en
avait peut-être do wah wah classe et le
reste va vraiment vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de français et de belges et
ceux qui arriveront tu ne connais ont
cette connaissance de base des
autochtones où vous avez encore là un
apprentissage à faire alors que ce soit
des québécois ou des ou des européens
le niveau de connaissance
les réalités autochtones est souvent
extrêmement faible vous avez chez les
étudiants québécois des étudiants qui
sont passés par des cégeps où il y à des
pauvres sur les autres femmes qui sont
donnés par des personnes compétentes et
où il invite des conférenciers
autochtone aussi hélas bien sûr ça fait
une différence majeure parce que ils ont
nettement des connaissances par rapport
aux eaux mais c'est encore une minorité
et où un peu partir de zéro c'est à dire
qu'il ya là beaucoup il j'en ai même vu
qu'ils ont vécu à côté de pommes une
hauteur pomme toute leur jeunesse et qui
ne savent même pas le nom de la
communauté ni le nom de la première
nation on vous dira part de loin ma part
d' extrêmement oui oui mais je pense que
au delà des universités pour les
personnes qui sont des allophones
il ya beaucoup de connexions qui se font
à l'extérieur date et aujourd'hui tard
particulièrement à cause des médias
sociaux
ça nous permet d'en apprendre beaucoup
plus de voyager à travers tout ça je
pense que ado nomaou c'est apporter nos
sensibilités pour le mouvement
antiraciste particulièrement et moi
quand je regardais la communauté
haïtienne il ya des liens qui est quand
même assez fortement et même avec la
communauté algonquine il ya même une
déclaration qui a été fait de
reconnaissance du peuple haïtien aussi
pour le reconnaître comme un peuple qui
est des partis aussi d'autochtones et
c'est donc et beaucoup de choses qui se
font dans ce sens là mais malgré tout et
on va apprendre à travers les médias
sociaux on va apprendre à me verser dans
des écoles certains détails
c'est sûr qu'on n'apprend pas tout et
moi ma première et et la plupart du
temps juste pour compléter la dessus de
la plupart du temps les gens ne vous
êtes même pas les territoires des
premières nations donc ils ne
connaissent pas cette réalité là où ne
parle pas forcément avec des gens qui
sont issus de ces communautés là et moi
j'ai eu la chance d'aller à plusieurs
reprises quand j'étais plus jeune et je
voyais des exemples désastre de pauvreté
des toilettes à l'extérieur
suite et quand j'étais employa la grc
quand je te réagir si ce travail sur un
territoire des premières nations et pas
m'exposer exactement et j'ai travaillé
qui n'associe pas qu'ils aient
nord-ouest au manitoba et c'était la
première fois que je pouvais faire des
analogique ce que j'avais vu en haïti
exactement et de voir qu'il n'y avait
pas d'eau courante qui avaient pas accès
à certains services les maisons étaient
remplis de gens et délabré ainsi ça a
été un choc
c'était un choc pour moi de voir ces
conditions là que certaines communautés
parce que c'est pas toutes les
communautés y en a qui ont bénéficié de
sur les accords et à ses suites
mais ça a été un éveil énorme pour moi
personnellement qui a fait en sorte que
je dois en apprendre encore plus sur les
communautés autochtones et je pense que
dans le mouvement antiraciste
particulièrement ici à travers tout le
canada
les gens sont extrêmement sensibles à
ces enjeux là on va m'en suis toujours
les territoires donc céder on va
s'assurer d'avoir des personnes
autochtones on va même faire des
célébrations au début à des événements
sécurité des gens qui sont issus de ce
territoire qu'on puisse le reconnaître
donc je pense qu'il ya un énorme travail
de reconnaissance qui est fait par les
mouvements antiracistes peut-être plus
que les communautés d'origine
canadienne-française
alors vous étiez policiers dont vous
êtes allés dans des communautés comme ça
dans le cadre de votre travail de
policier est-ce que automatiquement dans
votre tête vous vous ai dit bon une fois
que j'ai quitté la police je veux faire
du documentaire je vais m'intéresser
aussi à cette réalité que j'ai vu là sur
le terrain mais la réalité que j'ai vu
pour moi comme policier noir et avec mes
collègues étaient blancs déjà les
connexions se faisaient beaucoup plus
profondément avec les communautés
autochtones y avait une reconnaissance
et même la culture la musique je
regardais les jeunes je coachais basque
et bal à cet endroit et les jeunes
écoutaient beaucoup ce type de musique
là mais en même pas il m'a mené vers la
musique traditionnelle et est donc
c'était vraiment facile pour moi d'avoir
des conversations sur des rails et et
qu'on pouvait partager
est ce que vivait aussi comme exclusion
racistes et ensuite on se comprenait un
peu dans série terra et culturellement
aussi à beaucoup de choses qui sont en
lien avec même les communautés
haïtiennes les communautés noires estieu
donc c'était quand même assez facile
comparativement à d'autres personnes et
il ya même des endroits parce que
c'était un drive réserve donc une
c'est exactement mais il y avait des
endroits sur le territoire us qu'on
pouvait aller consommer il ya un mort et
les policiers n'avaient pas le droit
d'aller dans ce lieu et moi j'avais le
droit
donc c'est juste pour vous dire que ce
chemin là était beaucoup plus facile et
je continue à engager ces conversations
la de plus en plus parce que je pense
qu'on a besoin de connaître cette
histoire là qui a encore trop absents
dans les communautés à neuf années est
vraiment un mec là parce que si on reste
dans un cadre universitaire académique
insultes
l'accès est pas pareil pour tout le
monde ça c'est la réalité
malheureusement donc comment qu'on fait
pour rendre cet axe-là beaucoup plus
présent en comprenant c'est quoi ce truc
sur la quête alentours de nous qu'on ne
va pas voir mais qu'on doit absolument
aller à la rencontre dans le respect
aussi pc d'en apprendre le plus possible
nous autres même vous parliez du film
que vous prépariez sur fredy villanueva
et vous avez fait le lien avec la crise
autochtone à au cas où quelques années
ça la clé en 1990 pourquoi avoir intégré
au cac année s'attaquer cette réalité là
avec ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire
de fredy villanueva ce jeune qui a été
abattu à montréal parce que je pense que
l'histoire de fredy villanueva
quand la connais qui se bat par un
policier dans un parc alors qu'il jouait
dans un parc louis et qui reçoit un
manque d'empathie total la communauté
québécoise
moi je me posais la question d'où
provient ce manque d'empathie pour les
communautés autochtones mais aussi les
communautés allophones et ça pour moi
c'est un peu le réceptacle de toutes les
conversations qu'on a évité d'avoir au
québec et la crise d'oka est un moment
fondamental pour seront n'a pas parlé de
ces enjeux là ici au québec comme on
aurait dû en parler
après ça il ya eu le référendum
wasquehal cas de jacques parizeau
meilleurs judokas aussi que de rester ce
qui était assez évident et encore une
fois on a évité ces conversations loeb
ensuite on se rencontre on se rend dans
la crise des accommodements raisonnables
est de plus en plus une grande frange de
la population québécoise a aucune
empathie pour les gens qu'on qualifie la
diversité même ceux qui sont ici depuis
des milliers d'années et je me pose
cette question là si on se rend jusque
là et si on n'a pas eu cette sympathie
là pour fredy villanueva quand il se
fait à bad à ce moment-là président
allemand
est un personnage qui est désagréable
pour la population québécoise parce
qu'il représente cette diversité là
qu'on veut cacher parce qu'on a pas vous
avoir ces conversations là donc je vais
tout ce voyage je trouve qu'il ya un
paradoxe au québec présentement c'est ce
que je me posais la question ce que les
choses se sont améliorées par rapport
aux connaissances ou à l'ouverture des
québécois par rapport aux autochtones et
est ce que je vois puis je mens tendance
que oui il dit aussi c'est que il ya une
partie une tranche de la population qui
se montrent très ouverte qui veut aller
qui veut connaître qui veut qui est très
sensible oui mais malheureusement en
même temps que cette partie-là grandi
une autre partie de la population qui
voit un peu à peu se radicaliser mais en
tout cas qui vaut prendre une tangente
beaucoup plus fermé à 10 ans et actions
en réa voyons exactement ayant un
paradoxe là que je vois de plus en plus
pu malheureusement ces gens là pour que
j'écris puis pour qui je fais ce que je
fais la partie justement qui veut rien
entendre
c'est devenu de plus en plus difficile
chez possible tu le sens de la même
manière absolument que ça devient
frustrant de ne pas pouvoir engager ces
conversations parce qu'elles sont basées
sur des préjugés et des stéréotypes et
c'est vrai qu'à une grande frange de la
population qui est de plus en plus
ouverte et c'est magnifique on est
heureux d'entendre c est ça fait
beaucoup plus de recherches prouvent en
lsf richesse pour l'ensemble du québec
mais c'est dommage parce que c'est petit
voilà où ces voix là prennent de plus en
plus d'ampleur on y voit dans les
maisons en dur ou dans les journaux ils
ont accès à des médias comme peu plus de
personnel et ça fait en sorte que le
dialogue malheureusement ne souffre pas
et se ferment et les gens sont devenus
complètement muller mais comme les
huîtres et ça crée des séquelles
malheureusement c'est ça qui est dommage
comment qu'on fait pour réouvrir ses
conversations le mans c'est la plus
grande question que je me pose on va
tout de suite se tourner vers hellich
parce qu elle va nous amener dans le
grand nord avec un homme qui lui est
originaire de la floride alors attendez
il s'appelle peter ording c'est un
anthropologue d'ailleurs comme marie
pierre professeur à l'université de la
floride il a écrit un livre sur une
petite communauté inuit
il a découvert il ya très très longtemps
il était tout jeune en fait quand il s'y
est rendu
comment est ce que lui même s'est
intéressé à cette petite communauté
d'une
mais nous n'avons août non le rapt accès
wifi à nos meilleurs acteurs qui même
les canadiennes qui savent pas que ça
exige que ça existe en arctique
pour lui c'était un peu par hasard un
collège aux mines dans nos mines pour
lincoln avec une musique très reconnue
aux pôles arctique et c'est une
professeur qui est wenger qui proposait
à lui de commencer le projet de
recherche ici dans la communauté ce qui
est très intéressant au juste dans
l'équipe est une île arctique minutes il
était au canada si de la dernière d'être
colonisé est alors à cause de toutes ces
transformations
ça se fait donc quelques minutes est
dans une génération on va dans une
culture de la chasse oui jusqu'à une
cousine certains oui et ce qui est
intéressant que quand on est dans des
communautés dont on entend de tout le
temps y est les chercheurs qui viennent
de nos communautés tout le temps il
reste trois semaines il dit qu'ils en
expert pierre par les gens viennent pour
leur agenda de recherche ne sais pas ce
que nous on a besoin ici et ce qui est
intéressant même il ya 30 ans quand il
était dans le nord et blues se servira
des communautés et de vraiment exploré
les vies des hommes non il ya énormément
de travail qui a été fait sur les jeunes
et puis les années sauf le le stade des
hommes entre l'âge de 20 ans et 40 ans
et 50 ans maintenant que ceux qui
minutes ils sont sédentaires
il est très doux qui était connue sur
leur vie et pièces qui commet appris que
ça maintenant que le chasseur puis 1 200
rôles dans les communautés c'est l'état
qui appuient le rôle de l'homme dans la
société news comment les hommes dans la
vingtaine de tentes en quarantaine
comment il construit la valeur
maintenant comment ils enlèvent leurs
enfants c'est quoi les valeurs qui veut
le transmettre
oui et on y est c'est très rare parce
que même aujourd'hui jeudi dans les
structures populaires dans les
journalistes eux mêmes
on parle de 1 minute où le chasseur mais
c'est quoi la vie intérieure c'est quoi
ces valeurs
et puis après 30 ans est sorti ce livre
c'est becoming numérique et numérique
c'est un mot en une nuit d'acteur
et ce à la notion de une personne
authentique ou avec la notion de
s'épanouir en france et aussi est il
écrit ce livre on suivant ces zones dans
la communauté et leur vie quotidienne
il nous comment quand il fait quand ça
va mal comment il fait pour se remettre
quand il dirait que les enfants et même
ses deux livres quand les gens me
demandent de quel livre il peut lire
pour mieux comprendre le nord je suggère
ça parce que il fait une très très bon
job d'expliquer leurs items d'une
communauté et la culture nous aide mais
pas dans les thèmes de l'occident elle
décide de refléter les rythmes de la
communauté au lieu d'imposer notre point
de vue où il devrait de montrer
d'ailleurs oui allez encore une fois une
société encore disponible en français
mais c'est comme devenir et noom arik
levy des hommes dans un chi minh au t1
où est d'accord c'est le ferai tout et
dont on va la montre et oui on peut
revoir
voilà un oui l'autre côté mais en fait
ce livre là il l'a sorti à combien de
temps ça senti en 2014
d'accord alors que lui c'était il ya une
trentaine d'années qui était là quand il
a passé une année sa première année avec
avec les gens de cette communauté à
celle vécue la whey une année comme
orléans là et depuis trente ans il fait
la navette entre la floride et people
chi minh et éloge et même maintenant
avec ces projets de recherche et me
donner un exemple comme juste récemment
il voulu aller dans nos communautés pour
fait la sécurité alimentaire une gros
gros enjeu dans l'api canadienne mais la
communauté gay dit écoute on a tout le
monde qui viennent ici c'est pas pour
nous dans cette communauté dans ce lieu
qui est notre priorité pour nous c'est
la santé et puis le dit ok je vais faire
une projet sur ça et dans la communauté
même avant que cd v sortie moi j'étais
là pour faire des reportages et d'hommes
c'est inutile c'est très très éloignées
ce qu'il pense des fois toujours que
tout le monde qui vient de l'extérieur
se connaît et tout le monde est demandé
est ce que vous connaissez twitter et je
ne savais pas que je m'en doutais le
vois vraiment comme quelqu'un qui est le
service de la communauté
et pas comme il est là pour apprendre
quelque chose
oui dont il a acquis le respect des gens
comme moi tu es contrairement à tous ces
chercheurs qui viennent et qui vend dans
les communautés où es tu ne restes pas
ça change aussi intéresse plus après les
chercher
je vois maintenant ils font beaucoup
plus d'efforts dans la communauté dans
l'arctique
mais c'est quand même cool c'est ce que
c'est juste avec lui ce qui est
intéressant qui le fait soi même avant
que celles venues ou de mauvais ans
maintenant et aussi c'est comme même
après contrarier défaut les conflits ou
les malentendus mais ils sont capables
que je vous de régler ça parce qu'il
respecte les liens de confiance qui sont
tissés depuis c'est intéressant parce
que j'avoue je vous pose la question
parce que de beaux et anthropologique
historiques comme géologue est ce moi je
regarde la communauté haïtienne
c'est la première communauté qui a
réussi à se libérer d'un esclavage donc
qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens qui
arrivaient fraîchement malheureusement
d'afrique et à travers ça vu cette
libération
on a pu décontaminer beaucoup l'apport
des européens 'sur point de vue culturel
donc je me posais la question justement
parce qu'on a pu préserver beaucoup de
choses culturellement comparativement
aux autres ils sur les antilles et ça
elle le fait d'avoir été une communauté
qui a été si longtemps isolé est ce
qu'il ya une plus grande préservation je
demande à cette culture la rose oui oui
et aussi l'attrait de transmettre la
culture est plus facile parce qu'il est
tout jeune génération qui se rappelle
comme c'était avant que les autres
étaient arrivés et on dirait que dans
ces communautés l'oeil - détention - des
défis qu'on voit dans d'autres
communautés où ça fait plus dans le
temps et puis les gens sont minutes mais
les gens qui pleurent de m'apprendre
c'était quoi ces valeurs mais ça fait
trop longtemps mais puise dans les
transmissions de culture ça se fait plus
facilement
je pense que vous avez raison merci
hellich marie marie marie pierre oui
avez oublié votre prénom presque
j'allais dire marie claude marie pierre
les chercheurs serait pas la première
fois non
vos chercheur au département j'imagine
que les gens vont sur le territoire vont
souvent sur le terrain
est-ce qu'ils prennent le temps
lorsqu'il arrive dans une communauté de
travailler avec les gens du territoire
de comprendre comment ils vivent
est ce qu'ils essaient de s'adapter
culturellement aux gens qui sont sur le
territoire et qu'ils vont étudier
écoutez je peux pas parler pour tout le
monde parce que je les suis pas tous ce
que je sais c'est que moi dans
l'anthropologie de la manière dont j'ai
été éduqué à l'université c'est que pour
être un bon entrepreneur pour être un
bon ethnologue
il faut comprendre le point de vue des
gens et il faut vivre avec eux suivre ce
qu'ils font et faire vraiment ce
s'impliquer dans la vie locale
alors après ça est ce que tout le monde
a envie de faire je sais pas on assiste
beaucoup maintenant faire des
collaborations mais parfois ces
collaborations peuvent être passés
invasif pour les communautés parce que à
force de vouloir être être
collaborateurs on s'y prend pas toujours
très très bien donc c'est parfois très
lourd pour une communauté de
d'accueillir des chercheurs il faut
savoir à un moment donné comme chercheur
aussi partir pour pour que les gens
puissent avoir l'impression qu'ils sont
pas toujours surveillés
objet de recherche recherche c'est vrai
c'est un peu pénible d'avoir toujours
quelqu'un qui est toujours là puis moi
des moments où je vais dans des
communautés et pas du tout pour faire de
la recherche j'y vais parce qu'il ya des
gens que j'ai envie de voir ses poufs
aussi prendre le temps de faire autre
chose que de la recherche
il m'arrive de prendre des vacances là
bas mais après ça dépend des individus
il faut va vraiment ce qu'est ce qui est
enseigné maintenant c'est d'avoir des
relations les plus proches possibles
avec les gens après ça il ya aussi des
questions de personnalités un ca c'est
assez difficile parfois de trouver le
bon équilibre entre sa vie personnelle
et son application locale
oui il oiseaux je vous abandonne pas
vous êtes le correspondant vous est-ce
que vous traitez régulièrement dangereux
autochtone oui mais tout à l'heure je
pense que j'ai été je me suis mal fait
comprendre que j'étais un peu agressif
et je me suis mal fait comprendre oui ça
m'intéresse et je lis énormément je suis
abonné à pas mal de deux revues
amérindienne on va dire pour simplifier
comme ça la plupart viennent des états
unis elles sont en anglais je regrette
qu'en france en français il n'y ait pas
grand chose n'est pas une agence de
presse par exemple comme il a plusieurs
qui existent du côté anglophone aussi
bien aux états-unis qu'au canada
et oui j'écris beaucoup là dessus oui
parce que je voudrais juste dire un mot
sur les changements moi je suis un blanc
je suis né blanc je resterai blanc j'ai
un passeport français j'ai fait j'ai
suivi des guerres pendant toute ma vie
donc j'étais au contact des colonisés
aussi bien en afrique qu'ailleurs et je
retrouve quelque part quand je vais dans
les communautés amérindiennes un peu le
même type de comportement qu'ont les
gens à mon égard je le comprends
parfaitement ça je le comprends
parfaitement ce que ce que je voulais
dire c'est que on est peut-être aussi en
passe de changer nos comportements
par nécessité parce que quand on parle
de l'écologie c'est là une de 2,2 de
tout le monde en ce moment dans le monde
entier on parle de ça là on a l'immédiat
des références claires parce qu'on a
tout à apprendre des communautés
autochtones
quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit en
amérique du sud où il ya aussi entre
guillemets des indiens ou ici quand on
regarde le comportement des communautés
autochtones au québec par rapport à la
nature
héééé la charge qui a été fait par le
capitalisme sur ces populations
notamment dans le traitement de la forêt
on est on est en droit maintenant
d'écouter
on a beaucoup parlé moi je sais que tu
fais c'est mon péché je m'en excuse
on a beaucoup parlé maintenant on doit
écouter et ça c'est un comportement qui
à mon avis va changer dans les rapports
qu'on peut avoir
noob lent qu'on soit québécois ou pas
avec les autochtones
isabelle
ces gens ont tendance à de plus en plus
écoutée je pense que oui mais avant
d'écouter il faut quand même avoir une
base connaître parce que sinon on va
être rempli de préjugés qu'on va écouter
puis ça mènera à rien donc l'éducation
je sais que je relève et c'est
extrêmement c'est le nerf de la guerre
l'éducation a besoin on qu'on doit déjà
des les programmes scolaires primaires
secondaires renseigner sur les réalités
autochtones oui l'histoire mais on n'est
pas cantonnée a vendu 750 comme c'est le
cas présentement dans les programmes
scolaires
on vit aujourd'hui nous réalité qu'est
ce que c'est oui il faut savoir écouter
puis je reviens aussi je fais un peu de
me la chance que marqueur disait les
anthropologues qui viennent chez nous
aussi la différence entre un bon
entrepreneur depuis un mois est bon
entrepreneur oui disons c'est le temps
qu'il faut passer dans la communauté
ouais si on vient pour faire une
recherche et claire en cinq jours
malheureusement vous aurez pas et si
vous restez quelques mois vous créer des
liens ça va vous ouvrir des portes où
vous vous auriez même pas pensé aller
voilà va vous emmener ailleurs donc elle
est toute la différence les liens
écouter le respect tout est là c'était
l'exemple que vous avez avoué elichabe
avec cet homme là est moins aigu depuis
geste pourrait renchérir ce qu' il avait
le dis aussi dans un processus de
décolonisation aussi parce que c'est un
peu sont les tmt par l'histoire
occidentale
ça libère même des gens dans l'aîné au
militantisme que je pourrais dire
surtout ici des communautés lgbt qu il
est bleu c'est un petit sourire qu'on
regarde moi j'ai encore faire un mélange
avec l'histoire haïtienne que l'histoire
tokten qu'en regardant nos communautés
le vaudou on a ce qu'on appelle les lois
et quand il ya des cérémonies les lois
vont nous envahir
et on peut être un personnage qui de
jean phi mené on peut être personnages
quittent genre masculin peu importe
dreux notre notre genre et ça ça fait
partie de nos cultures et quand je
regarde les to spirit soucis dans les
communautés autochtones tout à fait
libérateur aussi pour beaucoup de jeunes
donc plus on en apprend sur l'histoire
plus on des colonies aussi parce qu'on
apprend d'autres faits
d'ouverture sur différents genres qui
sont déjà présents depuis des années des
années des années en fait des milliers
d'années donc c'est juste l'histoire des
centres peut-être qui a fait beaucoup de
dommages mais il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut apprendre qui peut réparer
justement c est ce qu une dernière
question rapidement parce qu'on doit
terminer à 13 heures monsieur loiseau
quand vous préparez des reportages sur
les autochtones présenté en france en
europe
est ce que vous essayez justement de
décoloniser leur leurs pensées ce qu'ils
ont comme préjugés sur les autochtones
bonne que c'est pas évident donc c'est
pas évident du tout bon moi j'ai
tendance avec mon histoire mais avec
tout
je sais pas comment dire là la modestie
obligatoire j'ai tendance à essayer de
livrer le produit de la façon que selon
moi les autochtones le verrai mes
appropriation culturel donc il faut
faire très très attention mais c'est ça
à mon avis qui est intéressant donc
l'idéal ce serait que ce soit les
autochtones eux mêmes qu'il fasse son
travail
mais c'est très difficile parce que on
évoquait tout à l'heure avant l'émission
la france et les difficultés qu'il ya à
proposer des sujets comme ça les sujets
qu'on peut proposer en france sur les
autochtones
bon je fais caricaturé à l'outrance mais
c'est rempli de plumes et et de régaler
à
bon j'ai pas encore réussi à vendre un
sujet sur les problèmes de l'eau dans
une communauté
pourtant c'est ça qu'on devrait aller on
devrait apprendre à connaître sur ce qui
se passe dans la réalité standing rock
j'ai pas réussi à le placer pourtant
c'était quand même phénomène qui recoupe
tout un tas de choses sur le territoire
sur l'écologie sur voilà faut pas rêver
comme on dit et encore du travail il
faudrait les femmes l'éducation en
france oui absolument c'est vrai tout à
fait exactement
merci à tous d'avoir participé à cette
grande table ronde
marie pierre bousquet qui est dans son
chalet bien installé merci à très
bientôt mari pierre marie pier a disparu
elle est figée sur notre image
will prosper merci beaucoup soit un
documentaire éventuellement sur les
autochtones
j'ose espérer que ça soit - safran
collaboration un travail co-création
tous d'accord monsieur l'oiseau merci
beaucoup et l'oiseau journalistes
correspondants ici au canada merci
infiniment et ellis queen merci beaucoup
à la semaine prochaine il a belle picard
merci à la semaine prochaine et merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis à la
semaine prochaine à vous si vendredi
prochain à 12h15 au revoir